PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ELECTED ON
THAT WOULD MEAN BUILD THE WALL
AND NO AMNESTY.
SOME REPUBLICANS INCLUDING THIS
GUY WHO BELIEVES THAT THE DACA
AMNESTY THING IS A WINNING IDEA.
ONE IS HERE TO DEFEND THAT.
THAT'S SCOTT TAYLOR FROM THE
SECOND DISTRICT OF VIRGINIA.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
YOU WROTE A LETTER TO PAUL RYAN
AND 34 FELLOW CONGRESSMEN SIGNED
IT.
YOU SAY IT'S AN IMPORTANT AGENDA
TO GIVE 800,000 PEOPLE BROUGHT
HERE AS YOUNG PEOPLE AMNESTY?
OF ALL THE THINGS WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IN THIS COUNTRY, WHY
YOU OBSESSED WITH CATERING TO
THE NEEDS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS?
>> YOU USED 2 WORDS I TAKE ISSUE
WITH.
NUMBER 1 IS HAM NESTY.
-- AMNESTY.
I WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND MY
PERSONAL POSITION YOU AM WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
WHAT PRESIDENT OBAMA DID WAS
ILLEGAL.
I SUPPORTED MORE MONEY FOR
HOMELAND SECURITY.
FOR THE WALL.
THINGS.
GET MORE SECURITY.
WE SHOULD HAVE A PROGRAM --
>> Laura: ARE YOU AGAINST CHAIN
MIGRATION?
>> YES.
LET ME FINISH.
LET ME FINISH WHAT I AM SAYING.
I AM FOR THOSE THINGS.
GET THEM SAFELY BACK TO THEIR
PARENTS.
AMNESTY BY DEFINITION IS
FORGIVENESS FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
OFFENDED.
>> Laura: THAT'S CHUCK CHARM
>> Laura: THAT'S CHUCK SCHUME
>> Laura: THAT'S CHUCK SCHUMER'
>> Laura: THAT'S CHUCK SCHUMER'S
LINE.
>> I AM NOT CHUCK SCHUMER.
>> Laura: THEY SAY YOU ARE THE
REPUBLICAN PUSHING FOR DACA.
>> THAT'S COMPLETE CRAP.
I AM FOR A STAND ALONE THING FOR
MORE SECURITY FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT.
YOU HAVE GROUPS WHO PUSH THAT
MONEY TO ATTACK OTHER
REPUBLICANS.
I AM NOT FOR THAT POSITION.
>> Laura: YOU CALLED PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S RHETORIC DIVISIVE AND
BLAMED HIM FOR BLOWING THE
VIRGINIA RACE ON CNN.
VIRGINIA IS A BLUE STATE.
>> I DON'T AGREE WITH YOU.
>> Laura: OH, REALLY?
>> DO YOU WANT ME TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS OR ARE YOU GOING TO
KEEP STEPPING ON ME?
I DON'T THINK THAT VIRGINIA IS A
BLUE STATE.
IF WE SAY BOB McDONALD'S
ELECTION IN 19
ELECTION IN 1
ELECTION IN 20
ELECTION IN 2009
ELECTION IN 2009 W
ELECTION IN 2009 WAS
ELECTION IN 2009 WAS A
ELECTION IN 2009 WAS A R
ELECTION IN 2009 WAS A REV
ELECTION IN 2009 WAS A REVER
ELECTION IN 2009 WAS A REVEREN
ELECTION IN 2009 WAS A REVEREND
--OO
>> Laura: IT DIDN'T WORK.
YOU THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
DEVICIS?
>> YES, THE POLLS SHOW THAT.
I SUPPORT MORE MONEY FOR THE
WALL.
YOU SAY YOU SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT.
HIS POSITION IS LIKE MINE ON
IMMIGRATION.